foreign
[Music]
let's play a game with curious
chimpanzee who's a long time viewer of
the Stream
and let's go for it with 1e4
yeah as Jan said I thought it was more
than impressive well we have another
chance to play an elephant
and we Face D5 so I remember that
previously I've played
uh this line against curious so let's
see if he
uh has picked up some of the theory
of course here we play e65 Queen takes
D5 and D4
we've had this particular position many
many times uh highly highly theoretical
black plays Knight F6 which is the main
move and of course we respond by
developing our own night Knight F3
this is all Theory and here black is at
a major crossroads there are four
or so options that are all worthy of
attention and one of them is indeed a
knight to C6
now
Knight C6 is probably the move that you
would be making if you were looking at
this for the first time from Black's
perspective the drawback of 90s Knight
C6 is that the bishop on f8 remains
locked behind the E7 pawn and according
to the new allop and chessable course
the best way to try to punish the move
Knight C6 is precisely by exploiting its
principal drawback which is that when
white plays DC black is unable to
recapture on C5 with the bishop and if
black has to take on C5 with the queen
then it gives white a bunch of Tempe
that we can use to accelerate our
development so the move here according
to the adjustable course is Pawn takes
Pawn
now of course Pawn takes Pawn
is is is a move that you might be
reluctant to play because it allows
black to trade queens and force our King
out into the center at the cost of a
pawn and you might also also think that
it's quite easy to win the C5 Pawn back
but that couldn't be further from the
truth so I am going to play DC even
though I'm pretty Rusty on the theory
after Queen takes D1 so if curious uh is
intimately acquainted with it then you
know then the position is going to get
sharp A5
so A5 is a very understandable move uh
he's preventing us from playing B4
but that doesn't mean that we have to
part ways with the C5 Pawn automatically
in fact we have many many ways
that we can try to cling to that pawn we
don't want to cling to it at the cost of
ruining our position we want to find
some sort of middle ground and if we're
giving that pawn away then we want to
find a good reason to give it away so
what are the options for defending this
Pawn straight away well one of them is
to play Bishop to E3 but as you know
from many openings the drawback of
Bishop E3 is that it runs into this very
annoying move Knight to G4
uh why is Knight G4 annoying because
naichi 4 threatens to eliminate the
Bishop from the board to ruin our Pawn
structure and then once black pushes E6
we once again have the problem with that
pawn so the move H3 comes to mind as a
candidate move in order to meet E6 with
Bishop E3 unfortunately black can fly
through a different airport black and
play Knight to D5 and it's essentially
the same effect or this bishop is
destabilized so I actually don't think
that we should go for that approach
now A3 E6 B4 fails tactically because
black will play a b c b and Knight takes
B4 you should know this from you know
the Queen's Gambit and other openings
where you get this Pawn this type of
Pawn that you're trying to defend
so I actually think we should take a
more indirect approach one of the
drawbacks of the move A5 is that it
weakens the B5 Square so you might say
okay well then let's play Bishop B5 but
Bishop B5 has limited value because
black can just play E6 what I like is a
very alopin-esque type approach to this
position that involves trying to get the
Knight to B5 and that seems very
promising to me because from B5 the
Knight will not only be aiming at C7 but
in the event the black pushes the E Pawn
which is very likely and let's play the
move Knight A3 as I'm talking about it
once black plays E6 or E5
and we respond with Knight tp5 we can
also stick the Knight onto D6
and what could happen then is the
situation where black takes on D6 and we
take back securing the bishop pair and
getting control of the dark squares and
even if in the subsequent complications
black wins that pawn on D6 back I still
think that we're gonna get the upper
hand in the resulting end game
so Knight A3 is a move that should be on
your radar if you're experienced in the
elephant I mean we've had plenty of
games where I made this move in the
middle game and it makes sometimes more
sense to people when there's a black
queen on D5 because then you can more
clearly see the effect of the move
Knight to B5 but even without the queen
Knight to C7 is still very much a threat
so Knight A3 is a nice flexible move
it's a developing move
and we're kind of waiting for black to
put his cards on the table
all right so it's a good sign that
curious is starting to think
well if black had played the immediate
E6 then of course we would have played
B4
and that I think is one of the
theoretical lines I'll open up the
chessable course after the game to check
in on what the actual main line is
according to the authors Knight to D5
okay
so very understandable move black is
trying to cover the C7 square but just
like the bishop on E3 is quite unstable
so is the Knight on D5 now some of you
might instinctively want to play C4 or
Bishop to C4 both of which are
reasonable moves I like Bishop C4 more
because it's a developing move
but the problem with Bishop C4 is that
black and respond with E6 and defend the
Knight and open up an attack on C5 and
in that subsequent position we actually
could trade on D5 and play the move
Bishop E3 and then we've basically
permanently secured our extra Pawn on C5
so that's one option one option is
absolutely to play Bishop C4 here and
Chase the Knight away
of course another option is to stick to
our guns and play Knight B5 and this one
I like even more because Knight B5
creates a very devious threat of C4 as
well as Bishop C4 and once this Knight
is dislodged whitesnite travels to C7
and it may seem like a case of one
moveitis like oh is this really such a
serious threat well it actually is a
very serious threat because in order to
defend against it black has to make one
of several major concessions black
basically has to ruin either his King
safety by moving the king to the D file
or his ability to Castle queenside by
moving the rook in either case black
basically has to waste a very valuable
move just to defend against the threat
of Knight C7
King d8 okay and now that we have
induced this particular move our Knight
on B5 is also just chilling
we could also go at it from the other
side with Knight to G5 and that's a more
common idea than you might think
sticking the knights on B5 and G5
hitting the F7 and C7 squares
so Knight G5 is a very interesting
approach black will probably respond
with 95. in order to defend F7 and if we
play F4 there ooh then black could try
to counter-attack our Knight with H6
I'll show that line after the game so
that's one way we could play we could
also play this more straightforwardly
just developing the bishop with Tempo
Bishop C4 looks like a great move as
well
I like Bishop C4 I think it's simple and
very strong
solidifies our advantage
Knight G5 is the move that you would
play if you wanted to win the game on
the spot
so Knight G5 95 C4 B4 I'm trying to
calculate that line out
it's a little bit hard to assess how
good that is for white in contrast to
just the simpler Bishop C4
Knight G5 very very tempting move
let's go for it let's go Knight G5 I'm
going for the throat this game
sorry curious I'm going for the throat
just intuitively this feels like it has
to be the right move
just intuitively it feels like Knight G5
is squeezes the most out of the position
and it's not such a big commitment right
you shouldn't think of a move like this
like a path of no return okay it doesn't
work out big deal we're not in
introducing any permanent weaknesses
into our position we're just creating a
threat and knights unlike pawns do move
backwards
okay and Bishop E6 immediately justifies
our move immediately because now we have
the standing option
of taking on E6 and to say that it ruins
black spot structure is basically to say
nothing it just permanently destroys any
semblance of normalcy that black has
within the pawn structure so I'm taking
those Double D pawns any day of the week
particularly Wednesday which would right
now is at the time of recording now if
you're a patent then you might say well
I don't have to take on E6 immediately I
can just sort of chill in this position
because The Bishop's not going anywhere
but
that doesn't mean you always have to do
that right just because you don't have
to rush a move doesn't necessarily mean
that you shouldn't play it if you can
avoid playing and I don't see a reason
for us to keep this Knight on G5 it's
not doing all that much
and we might save a Tempo on a different
move but I think we should play it
simple and just take on E6 while we have
the chance
so now we have a choice of different
squares for this bishop and it's pretty
self-evident to me that our next step
involves bringing this bishop out
now the pawn on E6 is now one of Black's
main weaknesses and we can attack it in
several different ways we can attack it
from a rook that would come to E1 but I
think I see an even more effective way
of really targeting this pawn and
solving several problems at once which
is a relatively unconventional form of
development which is why I think some
people might struggle to visualize this
idea it might not occur naturally to you
and yet I think it's quite strong now
yeah to get the bishop onto like either
the H3 or G4 Square
so there's two ways to do it you can
play Bishop E2 Bishop G4 which is
excellent or you could play G3 Bishop H3
which I call the hyperfian keto because
you know you're you're moving the bishop
in that direction but you're not fee and
ketoing it
both options are totally viable but I
like the look of G3 just because it's a
little bit more elegant
yeah let's go G3
what about C4 to Fork well remember that
the C7 square is already protected by
Black's King so we no longer are aiming
for uh the fork on C7 okay well now we
follow up with our plan Bishop H3 by the
way if you really look at
depositional play you sometimes see
people especially strong GMS play H4 in
these types of situations in order to
optimize the king Side Pawn structure
and to potentially be able to use that
pawn as a battering ram later in the
game here we have bigger fish to fry and
we have an opportunity to really go
after black in the center before he's
completed his development so it's much
more important to play concretely than
it is to make these you know beautifying
positional moves now the movie five
has a very obvious drawback which is
that the Knight on D5 has now lost its
support and the idea I use this phrase
very sparingly but it essentially plays
itself we want to put a rook on D1 we
don't want to attack this Knight in any
random way right if you play Bishop B6
then I can easily drop back let's say to
C7
and what have we achieved
so instead we need to move this King out
of D1 we can move it to the C file we
could move it to the E file it really
doesn't matter all that much
I like keeping the king closer to the
center in the end game also you should
notice the role that our pawns are
playing in restricting the mobility
heavily restricting the mobility of both
of black snides in particular the D4
square is covered the B4 and F4 squares
are also covered which was one of the
major appeals of playing G3 as opposed
to Bishop E2 Bishop G4 now we have a
devastating threat of Rook D1 and I
think black might be borderline dead
lost here
and it's not just because we have an
extra Pawn it's because Black's position
is completely in shambles
and Rook to D1 I don't think black is a
good answer to it
he can't Castle right the King has
already moved I think the old King E8
Rook D1
black and tried to defend the Knight
with Rook d8 but we can still play Rook
takes D5 there
Rook takes D5 and it's a classic trick
with Knight coming to C7 and picking up
the Rook again
no it's it's lost I mean black is
totally dead here
and that's how quickly this end game can
go bad for black when you when you start
making these concessions
yeah King E8 Rook D1 and then the Knight
can't move because of Knight C7
yeah E6 might be the only move E6 might
be the only move here
in order to gain a little bit of
breathing room for Black's pieces
of course in the event of E6 we will
take on E6 and essentially black can
resign there as well
what's the issue with Knight F6 well
then we give a check on D1
the king is forced to slide over to E8
remember that's partially why we put the
bishop on H3
it wasn't just to attack E6 it was so
that when black played E5 were also
containing the king and preventing it
from moving to C8
so Knight F6 Rook D1 King E8 Knight C7
and the game is over
when did he become so lost well first of
all this end game is better for white
I'm pretty confident that according to
Modern Theory this is not the best
choice for black that's why you don't
see a lot of top GMS going for the two
nights variation with Knight f696 okay
kudos to to Chimp for for finding E6
obviously we don't need to spend any
extra time here we can just grab this
Pawn it's a very low risk move
so these types of moves can be made very
quickly
now the Knight now has a big problem
because if it drops back to C7 then we
deliver a check on D1 we force the king
away and we win the Knight and then
there's Checkmate to follow with the
other Bishop coming out to G5
if black drops back the other way Knight
F6 is probably the only way to keep the
game going would be my guess
I think Knight F6 is the only way to
Stave off immediate defeat and then
we'll think I mean maybe bishop G5 maybe
Rook D1 check lots of candidate moves
there that all should win the game
Knight C7 played yeah well this is just
gonna lose Rook D1 Chuck
King he's seven and we collect the
Knight
and simultaneously deliver checkman.g5
GG
um
obviously a short game but an
instructive one nonetheless from a
theoretical standpoint because it shows
you how dangerous this end game is for
black even though White's King to begin
the end game is less safe
it's very hard for black to win this
Pawn back on C5
so I'll show you a couple of important
theoretical lines
definitely a line that you can play with
black if you're very well versed in the
theory
okay so E4 C5 c3d5
Ed Queen D5 Knight D4 Knight F6
so in terms of popularity in the
position after Knight F3 in terms of
popularity at like the over-the-board
level Bishop G4 and E6
uh outweigh Knight C6 in popularity
Bishop G4 is by far the most popular
move here there's Bishop E2 and Knight B
to D2
there's even Pawn takes C5 here which
has become very popular recently so even
here Pawn takes Pawn is a move
and what's funny is that in this
position black plays E5 and historically
this has been considered a bad line for
white but recently some GMS have
breathed new life into the position
because in this position it turns out
that white can still play B4
and this is a trick that you should be
very familiar with this does not lose a
piece for white because white can
counter-attack the bishop and basically
drive it out of its pinning position
which occurs in many many different
openings Bishop H5 you play G4
now the funny thing is
in order to Garner the maximum amount of
Pawns
black very often plays Knight takes G4
in these types of positions but it turns
out that white is the one who gains a
big initiative so here the line goes HG
Bishop takes G4
and what is the best way to solve the
problem of the night well basically you
want to avoid allowing Bishop takes F3
because that Forks the king in The Rook
so the move here is Knight B to D2
you're essentially forcing black to
recapture on F3 with a pawn
which puts an end to Black's initiative
on the king side and then it's White's
turn
to seize the initiative by completing
our development quickly
and you can do that in several different
ways I think Knight to C4 is considered
to be a really good move here
and black is just really badly developed
technically both sides only have one
piece developed but White's development
proceeds more naturally and it's quite
easy to win this F3 Pawn back it's an
unorthodox structure it's a hard
position to understand after Knight C6
the best move is Bishop H3
and the point is that after the trade
after the trade
um
we're gonna win the F3 Pawn back and
we're gonna have this massive massive
Pawn Phalanx on the queen side that can
often decide the game because a
well-timed B5 can send this Knight away
and then you could quickly push C6 and
create a passer so black is also having
a lot of difficulties finding sort of
suitable employment for the bishop
now so this line has suddenly become
very popular
so Bishop G4 is one option E6 is another
option and here our move is Knight A3 I
think we've already had a game in the
speed run with this line
and again same idea as we
carried out in the game after CD4 the
point is we play Knight to B5 and we
threaten the fork on C7 gaining a tempo
gaining a tempo
and black typically plays Queen back to
d8 or Knight out to A6 to protect C7
and then I think white has a modest but
stable Advantage if black plays Queen to
d8 then we can play Queen takes D4 and
go for a slightly better end game or we
can take back with a knight and white
just has slightly more pleasant
development here there's nothing major
to say about the position like this
there's a lot of theory here
lots of GM games
but this position is quite approachable
it's easy to play even if you don't have
like encyclopedic knowledge of of the
position the main move is actually
Knight B takes D4 but the engine move
and the way to get the biggest Advantage
after Queen td8 is in fact Queen takes
D4
and then if black plays Queen takes D4
it's already plus minus this end game is
incredibly nasty for black for much the
same reason that the end game we had in
the game was nasty black is no good way
to defend the C7 Square because the move
Knight A6 as tempting as it is it
basically freezes Black's situation on
the queen side black now has no clear
way to deploy the Knight black has to
keep an eye on the C7 Square the bishop
on C8 is locked out behind his pawns so
this should be visual it should be
visually apparent to you that this is a
bad a pretty bad end game
for example let's say Bishop F4 black
plays Bishop D7 and white just continues
developing no need to do anything
drastic here just play Bishop E2
there are two games in the database both
of them continued Knight D5
and in both of them white got impatient
and basically cashed his chips in for
the bishop pair and played Knight D6
joke of course this keeps a big
Advantage but the engine just likes
keeping the tension of Bishop G3
the engine just likes keeping the
tension of the bishop G3 it's plus two
so let's say Bishop E7 black develops
right hopefully I'm making a reasonable
move so far Castle's Queen side
continuing the development let's say
black Castle's King side
funny line if black Castle's Queen side
if black Castle's Queen side he gets
checkmated on A7 which is a Worthy
mating construction to be aware of
but if black Castle's King side we make
this simple improving move Bishop F3
then we bring the Rook to E1 and again
you might be surprised that it's plus
two that's a pretty drastic evaluation
but it really is that good just compare
the placement of the pieces and you will
see the black's position is not only
miserable but very hard to play because
black is running out of useful moves
this Rook can't move because A7 hangs
the other Rook can move to d8 and I'll
arm move Rook moves into E1 and Bishop
takes D5 is a threat and we could also
reposition the King on a safer Square on
B1
so just very very unpleasant annoying
endgame for black that's why Knight A6
is the choice of more top GMS here
but it doesn't fully solve Plex problems
I won a recent game here over the board
you play Knight B takes D4
so in this situation you don't recapture
with the queen you recapture the Knight
and again it's not easy to play Bishop
E7 most popular move
and you just develop your pieces Bishop
B2
you just develop your pieces castles
castles and as usual if black ever plays
E5 White's response is always going to
be the same if black ever plays E5 your
knight goes back to B5 and again you get
the situation where the Knight on A6 is
essentially out of commission and now
the pawn and E5 is another additional
weakness the black has to be saddled
with
hopefully this is making sense just a
little bit of an overview of the main
lines now let's get to the move that
happened in the game Knight to C6
so D takes E5 is far from the only move
although it is the engine's choice at a
very high depth so let's get straight to
that move
now it should be pointed out that Queen
takes C5
does not solve Black's problems as I
pointed out this gives white rapid
development and here the best move is
actually not Bishop E3 even though I
said it during the game I forgot the
best move yet again yet again is to play
the immediate Knight A3
heading straight for B5 black and lose
this really really quickly if he's not
careful so a couple of illustrative
lines let's say black plays E6
then our Knight jumps into B5
and already black is in big trouble
because if black plays Knight to D5
then white wins on the spot with the
move C4 same concept as in the game
because we're threatening the Knight on
D5 and if black counter-attacks remember
that you're also hitting the other
Knight so here you win on the spot
so black has to make a super awkward
move and kind of contort himself in
order to defend the C7 Square upon which
we can play Queen A4
and bring the queen out and black can't
go here because of the fork so
constantly black is you know stumbling
on his own feet here because because of
how cramped the position is
and after A6 Bishop F4 the game is over
because we have too many threats Knight
C7 and Knight D6
so this is a
already very nasty position
if black plays A6 in order to protect it
the uh B5 Square this is a very common
situation
B5 is protected but now c4 is incredibly
weak so now we can go Bishop E3 let's
say the queen swings over to H5
now we can play Knight C4
and our Knight is heading for B6 again
this is very very juicy
so no matter how you slice it and you
can look at this on your own a little
bit more there is also the move E5 here
which is a little bit more ambitious
than E6 it happens pretty often we play
Knight B5 a lot of GM games here Queen
E7 this is one of the main lines
and here according to the engine white
is slightly better but more importantly
the position is very easy to play you
play Bishop E3
and if black plays A6 your response here
is always going to be the same Queen to
A4
very important resource that pins the
pawn to The Rook and you might say well
why is that dangerous black can just
move the Rook well Flack moves The Rook
you actually Castle queenside
and this is the line I showed anybody
who says the elephant is a boring
opening you sack the Knight on B5
in order to get rapid development and a
huge attack Bishop takes B5 Bishop D7
uh defending the Knight
and of course you make a very calm move
very important just because you've
sacrificed a piece does it mean that
every subsequent move has to be a
sacrifice or has to be something forcing
you just bring your other Rook into the
game and that extra piece is the
difference between success and failure
and the attack black is paralyzed black
is no moves let's say that black tries
to bring his Bishop out with G6 well now
it's time for more tactics Knight takes
E5
Bang
Knight takes E5 and now Bishop G5
creating another pin
creating another pin and your pieces are
all just I mean you're just gonna
Massacre black here in the center
and then after Bishop G7
you have two pins this is one and this
is the other so both of Black's Knights
are pinned which means you have Rook
takes D7 winning the game really really
pretty line
really really pretty line
Knight takes D7 and Bishop takes D7
check
and then and only then do you recapture
the queen
so it's a cool line and it gives you a
sense of how promising this can be
and that's why I think Queen takes D1
King takes D1 is really the only viable
continuation for black from a practical
standpoint
uh and here we get into some very
theoretical Waters I don't want to bog
you down with too much exposition of the
theory because you can study it yourself
and you know I know that a lot of newer
players are watching me uh so it's
probably boring as it is I'll just give
you a sense of what the main lines are
and why black experiences problems so on
chess space the main move is E5 and it's
closely followed by Bishop G4 I actually
think A5 is not a bad move
it's uh it's been played but it does you
know it gives white a very Hefty
advantage
and my response by the way Knight A3 is
not best Apparently after A5 the best
move is in fact to play the simple
Bishop B5
and then to meet Bishop D7 just sort of
standard play the engine actually likes
ah okay okay there's a detail that I
missed according to the engine you go
rookie one E6 Bishop E3 and Knight D5 it
turns out is not very scary because you
can just park the bishop on D4 so this
is an important detail you can put the
bishop on D4 and if black ever takes it
then of course you can Rectify your Pawn
structure by taking back with a c pawn
and now you're just up a full Pawn
so
yeah but I still think after Knight A3
it's all about the Practical difficulty
of playing a position like this I think
black's position becomes very difficult
to play just because you have so many
holes and you have to be ultra precise
in order to keep everything secure
so instead the two most popular moves
are E5 and Bishop G4 in response to E5
white of course plays B4
and this is already very very unpleasant
uh if black plays E4 then you can always
swing the Knight into the square that is
now open the D4 Square
so the most popular move here after B4
is uh Bishop F5 but Bishop F5 okay it's
not particularly dangerous you can just
play Bishop E3
which is the best move and if black
Castle's Queen side then your king
slides over to C1 which is a very safe
square and it's already plus minus we're
following a grand master game here
baralovic against moyesenko
from 2007. and the best move here is
just to bring the other Bishop out to B5
you are not afraid of allowing Knight
takes C3 because you're a pawn up and
again black is experiencing major
problems with finding a suitable
developing Square for the bishop
there's also gawaine Jones game here
titled Arena Lee chess wow so white
actually played a lot of theory here in
a bullet game
F6
is what happened and now white can
improve the placement of our King with
King B2 then you can play Knight bd2
Rook D1 again black has no compensation
for the pun and remember that anytime
black tries to cut into the pawn chain
you can always just play A3 once
blackstroke leaves A8 you can just meet
A5 with A3
so that's one line the other move that
occurs very often is Bishop to G4
this is this would probably be my choice
if I knew nothing about the position
here you take the opportunity to bring
your Bishop out to E3
um now the main move is Knight C5 as we
discussed during the game and the engine
move is Bishop C4
this is kind of sort of an engine line
that is worth just memorizing because it
turns out that after Knight takes E3 F
takes E3 whites play hinges on a very
important subtlety
which is that after E5 you do not play
B4 in this position
the reason B4 is bad is because after E4
H3 we had a very similar position where
White's Bishop was still on F1
what's the chief difference well the
chief difference is that now black and
play F takes G2 and this is very very
unpleasant this gives black additional
Tempe that he can use black is better
here
instead what you do here is you play the
immediate H3 you sacrifice the C5 uh
five Pawn back
now it looks like black takes it and
black is completely fine but appearances
are misleading I analyze this position
and white is significantly better here
this can be a little bit hard to explain
it's about plus over minus plus it's 0.7
in this position
and I would say there's three reasons
that white is better in this position
the first is White's control over light
squares is more meaningful than Black's
control over dark squares notice that a
lot of the critical important squares in
the center are all light squares whereas
Black's Bishop is sort of biting on
granite on E3 and whites King is a very
reliable Defender yeah E3 is technically
a weakness but black cannot reinforce
the pressure on that pawn
reason number two is that White's Pond
majority is more mobile than Black's
Pawn majority comparing upon majorities
is a very good way of understanding the
position at a deeper level why does a
three on two black is a four on three
but that doesn't matter what matters is
that White's pawns are already ready to
rumble forward B4 A4 A5 and if black
plays A5 then he creates a gaping
weakness on B5
on the other hand Black's Pawn majority
doesn't roll forward very easily but I
can play F5 but black can't create a
past Pawn very easily and Black's Pawn
movements aren't very meaningful
the third reason is that White's Knight
has better prospects than its
counterpart notice that Black's Knight
on C6 is completely restricted by these
two pawns highlighted in yellow they are
controlling all of the knights potential
advancing squares whitesnite has many
different paths that it can take in
particular it has very easy access to
the E4 square and later on in the game
could potentially access The Outpost on
D5
so that is in in sort of verbally why
white is better now how does the how is
the game likely to unfold well if black
plays F5 then the engine move here
actually is immediately to start pushing
the pawns forward with A4
black plays let's say Rook d8 for
example right just making neutral moves
and B4
you just start grabbing space and
pushing Black's Bishop Away In Pieces
away and now A5
a lot of people newer players would be
tempted to go B5 who can tell me why
this is a bad move and if you're
watching on YouTube and you're sort of
newer to chess and you're a little bit
lost this is a good opportunity to
review some of the positional Basics why
is B5 bad but A5 is good
foreign
yeah it's because of Knight A5 and
what's happened is that you have allowed
black to establish a complete blockade
on the dark squares and you because you
don't have a dark squared Bishop your
pawns are now fully paralyzed so don't
get blockaded like that push the other
Pawn first now you're trying to go A6 in
order to soften up black snide on C6
now I hope my explanations earlier were
somewhat understandable and this is a
type of position that occurred in one of
the nepo ding games where black is now
saddled with permanent weaknesses of his
pawns and White's Knight potentially has
access to C5 and black can't Castle
because White's controlling the light
squares
so you know it's
it's good not to be dismissive and just
say oh this is too much for me to
understand I'm too new to chess you can
understand how such positions operate
and that is exactly how you learn about
positional chess how you learn about
maneuvering play and where pieces belong
it's by analyzing end games like this
one but the bottom line here is that you
do sometimes sacrifice the C5 Pawn back
in order to gain certain positional
assets in this case to reclaim the
bishop pair and to gain control over the
light squares by the way if after H3
black refuses to take the Knight
if black refuses to take the Knight
uh the move here
just a moment what is the move here
oh it's just G4 Bishop G6
and actually you go King E2 so you still
give the pawn back and then you go after
Black's Bishop with Knight H4 and then
you bring the other Knight out and again
your control over the light squares as
well as the prospect of pushing your
queen side pawns gives white an
advantage here despite appearances by
appearance this should be equal but
because of these weak squares white is
actually better here
so very instructive positional ideas
here on top of the sort of specifics of
the variation last thing I would say is
that you should not be afraid of getting
your king Side Pawn structure ruined
because here you also get the bishop
pair and white black has no easy path to
reclaiming the C5 Pawn because you can
always reinforce it with B4
and so I would say that black is in a
lot of practical trouble in this end
game of course if black plays Knight E4
trying to Fork these two pawns you have
Bishop E3 and this is why this line
works concretely you have this bishop E3
move to support both pawns at once
so in any case A5 Knight A3 is not the
most precise move
and the reason apparently well white is
still better apparently Bishop G4 chimp
is the best move here just quickly
prioritizing development rather than
trying to sort of artificially defend
the C7 Square the problem with your move
is that the Knight is very unstable here
that's like the bottom line problem with
Knight T5 the Knight is very easy to
kick out I would argue that after a
knight B5 black is already completely
lost unfortunately just because you're
suffering on all these squares
okay
yeah so Knight Z5 Knight B5 you're in
big trouble you have to get your pieces
out because that's the only way to
compensate for the loss of a pawn and
the thing is at this point I would not
play Knight B5 because this would run
right into Castle's Queen side and now
the Knight looks kind of useless now the
Knight looks kind of useless so after
Bishop G4 I probably would have played
Bishop E3
or or something of that nature and if
black castles I would have just shifted
the King around let's say that you won
and you know the game continues black
has some activity here I think white is
clearly better insufficient compensation
but you can continue playing so
something like this is what I would do
with black I would play Bishop G4
um if black plays D5 then White's idea
works like a charm here you play Knight
B5
and obviously black has no easy way to
defend against Knight C7 this is the
main idea
so 95 Knight B5 King d8 I think is I'm
not gonna say forced but I don't see any
other reasonable move here and now I
attack you from the other side Knight G5
I think that your only chance to stay in
the game would have been to play Knight
E5 I'm curious if you considered this
move because after Bishop E6 happens I
think the weaknesses of your Center is
just too much it's plus six
after 96.
so 95 only move to stay in the game of
course white has F4
and now you have H6 so this is one way
to not give up F7 with a fork but of
course white is still winning and the
simplest approach for white here is just
to grab the second Pawn just to grab the
second Pawn
and things are made even worse for Black
by the fact that E6 is now completely
impossible because the Knight will
always hop into D6
maybe Rook H5 can be tried here
but white can reinforce the bishop with
H4
another annoying detail
and F6 we can develop with Tempo like
this
so
just not good not good for black
uh but perhaps the game could have
continued a little bit longer after you
play Bishop E6 and I play G3 the game is
over do you just have too many
weaknesses this is coming out black is
paralyzed you're not getting your Bishop
out you tried your best your G6 was good
E5 I mean you played reasonably but the
I mean the Avalanche was just falling on
black here and you've got no
coordination no development
uh so so the biggest mistake the chief
culprit of course going into the end
game was one thing but this Knight T5
move right when you're a pawn down in a
situation and you've got a lot of
weaknesses generally prioritizing your
development prioritizing active
development is the only way forward if
you try to kind of bandage up your
weaknesses and put Band-Aids over all
the weak squares something's going to
give because you just don't have enough
Firepower to keep your pieces where they
belong if that makes sense
and this is exactly what happened here
you just start collapsing because you
just don't have the activity to keep
your knight firmly entrenched on D5 I'm
threatening C4 I'm threatening this you
know you've got problems on the D file
and so that's what tends to happen when
you try to play a little bit too
passively from a defensive side when
you're when you're in this type of
situation
so a nice elephant game thank you Jim
for uh for playing I appreciate I hope
you enjoyed the game a shorter one but I
still hope you found the opening
exposition to be relatively instructive
again the point is so that you're able
to watch these speedrun videos and
actually play the opening yourself so
this kind of doubles as an opening
tutorial even though we don't cover all
that much in the grand scheme of things
in every game
but still I mean hopefully you get a
sense of what people actually tend to
play
and so on that note I'm going to call it
a night because I want to get my seven
hours in before Arena Kings tomorrow
which I will be streaming in Russian
thank you everybody
lovely Blitz session today once again
hope you enjoyed it
and I'll see you guys tomorrow bye
foreign
[Music]